We're often appalled by how sly and dishonest many politicians are,
but we shouldn't be. In moods like this
we need to remember and read the works of Niccolo Machiavelli.
A late 15th century political advisor and political theorist
who argued that we shouldn't think that politicians are imoral
and simply bad for lying and dissembling and maneuvering.
A good politician, in Machiavelli's remarkable view, isn't one who's friendly and honest and kind.
It's someone, however occasionally dark and underhand they might be,
who knows how to defend, enrich and bring honor to the state,
which is also an extremely important goal.
Being nice may well be a virtue in general, but what citizens most need from their rulers
is effectiveness, which may well call upon some darker arts.
Once we understand this basic requirement,
we stand to be less disappointed and clearer about what we want from our politicians.
Niccolo Machiavelli was born in Florence in 1469.
His father was a lawyer
And so Machiavelli received an extensive formal education
and got his first job as secretary for the city of florence
But, soon after his appointment Florence exploded politically
And expelled the Medici family who'd ruled it for 60 years
And suffered decades of political instability and turmoil